I I do have a dark history with hook
tunnel Canon
that's the best one dude I love Pachinko
won so much money playing Pachinko it's
not even funny when I first came to
visit did you learn from the guy who did
that yeah it was the the host family I
came on for years and the dad or it was
her uncle he said like here's some uh
the New Years
money I was like I'm 22. and he's like
it's cool man because you're it's
usually for kids yeah right and uh he
took me to Pachinko and I was playing
some kurohige pom-poms pirate [__] and
it's like a [__] and I won like eight
hundred dollars
I felt so bad because I kept winning and
they kept losing money but they couldn't
leave because my chain bonus was out of
control so they're just sitting there
next to me they're like have you lost
yet and I'm like no man it keeps saying
dokan I don't know what's going on
here it's like explaining well and so I
won all this money and I was I was able
to get a a PlayStation 3 that was like
the White Version
because if you trade your balls for an
item yeah or for like
pieces of plastic that somehow someone
next door really wants to buy right and
then you you'll be like I'll trade you
this piece of plastic for like 200 he's
like okay and that's because it's
illegal to gamble yeah the loophole is
crazy so I was able to buy everyone like
dinner and I was like when I come back
to Japan I'm playing Pachinko again and
I started playing hooked on okin and I
had no [__] clue who was okay sure is
Raul or whatever I thought he was like
the best dude ever because he was so
strong
and I hated that joggy guy but I love
seeing him because he's the easiest to
win off of and like I knew of joggy I
knew every single element of these games
and I I've played every kid machine
that's ever come out yeah right and uh
kujin no Hoshi it's a baseball manga
from like the Edo period yeah I can't
say it right but those two games I still
yearly go on my pilgrimage with like 200
bucks and I either Break Even or I rake
in some cash anyway so have you actually
watched or red hooked on again uh I know
he knows he knows I know the songs I
know idle you know you are sure you know
you are shocked uh welcome to this crazy
oh my God I know all that [__] and I
know uh
and I used to make mistakes because when
Ken would show up on the screen if he
was doing something he'd go like yeah I
didn't know what that meant but it
sounded cold-blooded so I'd say that's
like teachers in my way and that means
like get the [__] out of here get the
[__] out of the way yeah and they would
be like and I'd be like Dolce which is
like remove yourself
sometimes uh this I remember I was like
this is why you shouldn't learn Japanese
from anime this was the worst example
though because I was teaching at the
first school I was teaching these
elementary school kids oh man it's so
bad this is so bad I don't know and
these kids were like seven or eight and
we were playing dodgeball and I had to
be on like the loser kid team and I was
like I'm not gonna lose to a bunch of
and this one kid kept talking [__] from
across the arena right and I was like
okay okay okay all right and every time
he threw it I would like you know catch
the ball and I'd be like you're out and
then he was like Baka and I was like now
wait a minute I'm a teacher son you know
I was like so I I felt really bad I
didn't throw it hard
that hard but I threw it and I uh he
ducked and I hit another kid in the face
who was not looking right and I remember
like we kept playing and then I finally
got the kid out and I was like quiero
it's like disappeared
disappear it's like I you will never be
reincarnated it's like your body is gone
forever and I remember I was and the kid
was like he thought that was really
funny so he we know I thought we
connected yeah and I felt bad for the
kid I bought him like an ice cream or
something else yeah sorry kid he was
fine but then the the gym teacher came
back and he he looked very flustered and
he wrote on like a little Post-It note
he must have been like scribbling
looking it up he was like these are
children please don't throw hard I was
like I'm so sorry but I was like he was
calling me vodka whatever
I [__] got him
all these you know right that was my
second week in Japan and so I'd already
been going through some phases where
kids like the Concho phase was very
popular where they where they do this
thing to teachers yeah yeah that was
really popular in the countryside so
like I said you had to make our own fun
now yeah you may think you're teaching
but overall you're more of an ambassador
and you're you're almost like a student
with the kids and a lot of the times
right you play the same games you you
eat the same lunches and you hear the
same jokes and obviously I learned very
quickly don't use phrases it would have
been absolutely legendary if you had
like cultable and you'd be like
so bad I didn't say that I'm so glad I
think piano is pretty bad though yeah
luckily the kid took it as a joke so as
well you got to use
I think I actually learned that from
like an RPG game because I always I'm a
subtitled dub I'm not dub guy right I
like yeah yeah
it was it was it was pretty enlightening
and I must say the other nine and a half
ten years I I was a very good person I
didn't take take it out throwing
dodgeballs at kids but yeah
eviscerated children hey man you can
only take so much physical abuse before
you're like look okay all right we're
all playing yeah
I play too you know you're pretty big so
you were stronger than me all right so
but yeah it was it was a good experience
and I it's kind of funny the the kid who
I said that to and uh some of those some
of those that that class yeah wrote me a
letter like three years ago saying that
they had finished like junior high
school or something yeah and that they
missed they missed uh Peterson say or
whatever so that's a lot yeah one class
that school yeah do you remember that
one teacher
good kids good kids good experiences but
yeah that's hooked and okay I do know
kinshido so like yeah hey wait is that
the the butler guy pouring drinks is
that you yeah well it's not me but
that's you I mean I mean a lot of girls
believed it for a while yeah just a
character I did a lot of impersonations
of on YouTube yeah and is that Snow
White on the other side that's uh one
piece that's one piece that is one piece
yeah yeah it's not the one piece it's
the character no I know I know Snow
White from the angle I saw it it looked
Vaguely Familiar that's Nico Robin
That's Nico Robin yeah she's a navigator
or something right okay
a bunch of nerds
actually yeah she's the archaeologist
okay you see the hero right okay well
you've seen like Ava oh [__] yeah this
is awesome yeah what the [__] is that
the boxer Joe guy nope
that's that's gone from Hunter Hunter oh
dear this is just a mess
um yeah this is a bit illicit I think we
can show that I think direct close-ups
um I know this because it's a video game
so near is cool yeah it's cool and I
feel like anime here's the thing I'll
say and why I I grew up reading comic
books right yeah comic books are cool
and they have some awesome stories yeah
but the reading slam dunk when I was in
nigata for like because uh I had nothing
to do yeah I was like crying at the end
of that story it's the only legendary
oh absolutely so good and I think what I
really respect about Manga and Anime is
they're not afraid to take risks with
their characters that American Comics
are like they'll kill people they will
do tragic stories and most importantly
their stories except for one piece and
you know what I mean like hey one piece
the fact that you have these cool
stories it's not like Spider-Man's back
for issue
1267. yeah and so all the characters
who've died and been around I like that
they have these single consequences
there's consequences I'll tell you a lot
of you say they end when you read the
one manga but you know that's actually
yeah well he wrote Vagabond too right
yeah he also wrote real as well which is
the wheelchair basketball that hasn't
ended either well all right take all of
it back Hey Man manga [__] man he's only
finished well I think there are other
stories like I bet fate Grand designs or
whatever ended right it's done
is King Arthur still slam fools
like 15 versions there's 15 versions
we're not going to get into that yeah
I'm fine and I it's wasted on me I don't
want to hear the voices of King Arthur
but like I've already done we have a lot
of voices if you stop playing face yeah
well too many way more than you heard
when you were doing your voice hey you
have no idea what gods I was listening
to no you're right it was uh you're
right you're right people Santa and fate
uh yes
be kinda it's Santa and face he's kinda
see it depends on like
yeah you know well I I think it's it's
something maybe I'll leave to The
Experts then and I'll stick with my
teaching and stuff